[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to introduce you to
a lady called rebecca murray i met
rebecca two years ago she's built up a
million pounds property portfolio she's
completely financially free and in this
video she's going to be explaining
exactly all the strategies that she's
used how she did it and how you can do
the same thing too so firstly rebecca
thank you so much for coming down to my
house no problem pleasure we met a
couple years back yeah what were you
thinking when you first met me
well i was a bit dubious all the online
stuff but i loved your youtube channels
and everything so we're just buzzing to
get started and just watch and see and
learn
so out of all the strategies that i
teach leased options rent to rent joint
venture buy refurbished refinance hmo
service accommodation
you've done every single strategy i
honestly think you're the first person
to come on winners on a wednesday that
is not just done but dominated in every
single different strategy in property
yeah well i've tried to just keep
everything you know not just to one one
strategy i wanted just to open my
options up so that's why i've just went
into the academy
looked at every strategy and just tried
everything so give me a little bit of
background
what were you doing before you became
full-time in property and got became a
property millionaire and what did life
look like and how has it kind of changed
uh well i've got science and graphics
business i've still do that now
alongside the property and so i was i
was involved in that 100
and i were looking for something else
just um alongside it and i came across
your youtube channels and and that
that's how i got into it really i knew
absolutely nothing about property i
owned my residential property but that
was it so now your portfolio
is valued at how much
two million
that's ridiculous i know you've done
that with joint ventures through the
academy which we'll talk about um did
you have a lot of money to start with
did you have like a load of money in the
bank and inheritance no how much money
to start with probably
a couple of grand
a couple of grand all right so you're
gonna need to tell us the secrets and
you're gonna need to share what you did
so your first property how did you
finance it what was it give me the
figures um so we're about to let and it
was mid-covered when everything stopped
everything shut down and we decided to
carry on plow through and we found this
deal decided to keep it because it was a
good little bite alert 50 000 pound
purchase price
um
and it took that long to go through i
think it took about 12 months to go
through there it were worth 60 when we
actually purchased it we sold the deal
in the meantime project managed the deal
as well so that paid for it it was a
free house to us okay
so you bought a house for 50 grand right
the deposit obviously is small you're
not talking a lot of money so you paid
for the deposit from packaging and
selling other deals
who did you sell that deal to
how did you package it and
what what was the deal it was just an
investor again through the academy and
through all our contacts and reaching
out on all the platforms all the social
media sites samuel lead
and we we generated a list from that put
the deal out to him and sold it yeah and
then they've asked they they actually
live in london so they asked us to
project managers
so you've got a finder's fee yeah you've
got a project management fee as well
yeah you took that money and then you
put that towards your little biter layer
yep genius yeah also as well your
company rave investments which again is
a joint venture rebecca and dave
rave which is absolutely awesome um when
did you realize when did you decide i'm
going to scale up really big now okay
i've got this little house i've packaged
and sold a deal i'm doing okay when did
you decide i'm going big i'm going to do
all the strategies and i'm going to
become a property millionaire from day
one
okay
we've no we've we've just continued
working throughout i mean we've been
working day and night with having our
own businesses alongside it's it's not
been an easy road at all it's day and
night and we've just been carrying on
and every opportunity has just you know
come to us or we've found it we've been
out there we've just been very very
active
and
networking across the samuel lee's
platforms networking across all social
medias and
and and got turning up going to the
events so it's all accumulated through
through being active really and i have
to commend your hard work because you've
literally just
got your head down cracked on with it um
your what's the cash flow then so i know
you've got a couple of million pound
worth of worth of property which is
which is rave investments which is a
joint venture with you and dave um but
still property millionaire even in your
own right because you know half of two
is one so congrats but cash flow how
much actual profit per month is your
company is your property company making
um on average uh 11 000 pounds
per month that's crazy
yeah i mean you must be pinching
yourself still sometimes and i am
because we've grew so fast as well yeah
if we we literally it's been 12 months
for rave investments so we've
accumulated that in 12 months it is a
bit of a
sometimes i'm just carrying on all the
time i don't even sit down to look at
the figures we're just on to the next
one the next one the next one and and
then when we finally sit down
it's like
really i know you're married i mean your
husband what does he make of all this oh
he thinks i'm crazy he
he does he he really really he just says
to me if there's anyone that can do it
you can do it he doesn't know anyone
that works as hard as me so and if i
want something i'll go and get it what
about the rest of your family how did
that how did they perceive this whole
thing i didn't tell anybody at first i
kept it really quiet and then as time's
gone on and i've grown
more and more people have got to know
when they've been really really
supportive
maybe because you didn't tell them what
you were gonna do you showed them what
you did exactly yeah i mean i got to a
point where i couldn't hide what i was
doing anymore it was all over social
media and
and
people
wanted seen in my different areas asking
me questions and even from the science
business
people started asking me and that like
i've i realized a lot of my customers
were in property
so we had something else to talk about
as well um
it just all tied in really nicely and
i've just plowed on
getting involved in everything where are
your renter rents
manchester city centre
a two bed apartment that
works really well and we've got one in
liverpool that we're turning into a
party pad nice a party pad see most
people do service accommodations say no
parties but you you're leaning into that
saying which is actually designed for
parties yeah so it's
a three-four block each floor sleeps at
eight people
um
and then the top floor would we're going
to separate them off we think for
couples
because we find that you know
when we've done our research that
there's not there's all these party pads
but where the couple's gonna go you know
they can go in the premier inns but it'd
be nice to have somewhere right in the
center next to
all the bars where they can go and enjoy
how have you done this so fast how have
you
learned all the ins and outs of rent to
rents and serviced accommodation and
gone and got a deal and got the money
coming in
alongside your signs business
how have you managed to do it so quickly
so much effort so much effort um just
being active and being involved and
speaking with people networking
and me and david work great as a team
you know we would bounce off each other
if i'm need to do something in my signs
and the property needs to do and he'll
do it and vice versa
and
and just really all the
keep watching the videos even now i
still go back to the videos just to have
a brief look because you forget because
i'm so busy doing so many strategies and
it's just a nice little reminder for
myself so you rent a rent you've got
your you've got your buy to let what
other properties have you bought and you
know i know you've done bio refurbished
finance how many hmos do you have four
four hmos
i mean talk talk to me about some of
these deals give me some of the figures
and have you managed to finance them
because you said you started with 2 000
pounds i get how you finance the first
one you just you just packaged and sold
a bit of deals made some it made some
money from being a property deal source
or and then put it in but how have you
managed to finance
four hmos i mean where did you get the
money joint ventures again through the
academy and uh people have actually
reached out to us said they want to join
venture with us they obviously see that
we're active we've we've got skin in the
game and you know they they trust us
they like us as people yeah joint
ventures uh they we've got two next door
to each other in burnley
and we're turning them into six bed hmos
and the basements we're gonna try to
split them and turn them into two bed
apartments so initially we could
actually sell the apartments on the
bottom off
and put some money into something else
and keep the six bed above so it's
really just about structuring the deal
and it's interesting because people
often ask me to say where where are
these joint venture partners and i think
that rather than looking for the joint
venture partners first firstly you need
to get the deals you need to get the
education you need to become valuable
when people come to me and they say oh
um i've got no money and i've got bad
credit and
what would you recommend i do i'm like
well stop counting what you haven't got
and start looking at the cards that you
have got and so actually how can i bring
value to a joint venture partner
yourself for instance you've project
managed deals you've gone on the academy
which is a really big investment you've
you've put money and time into education
you've spent hours and hours out in the
rain going i remember when we first went
into lockdown and everyone was all
worried oh man i'm going to lock down
let's wait and see what happens not you
you know you were out there going in
estate agents knocking doors and and
really pushing so of course then you're
going to be able to bring value to
somebody that's that wants to joint
venture with you but what advice would
you give
for someone that's looking for a joint
venture partner for someone that's
wanting um someone to put the money into
their deals what would you say first and
foremost get the deal get everything
tied up don't worry about that later you
know get everything together
and then you can present something
really good to them you know once they
see the figures
that at the end of the day that's what
they're after they want to see their
money's going to be put to good use
so we we got the deals worried about
that later once we packaged everything
up had builders there we knew everything
we were going ahead with it we didn't
even have the joint venture there you
know so would we would done it all would
and then all they had to do would come
in
bring the money in but we also offered
them to be involved if they wanted as
well like a bit of a learning
experience for them where does that
faith come from though because most
people wouldn't have the courage to do
that most people would think oh no no i
need to get all my ducks in a row i need
to wait for all the traffic lights to be
on green before i start driving because
finding a deal getting builders quotes
if you then end up not being able to
find a joint venture partner you're a
bit stuffed because you've offered you
spent time you spent a little bit of
money getting bills quotes
but you were just like
grab the deal sort the details out later
worry about that later that's an xyz
problem right now i'm in the abc
where does that courage come from years
of being in the business of
just in in a business really you can't
you can't
worry about them things or you'll never
get there
if it's a good deal and the deal stacks
it's going to go it's
you know it's a no-brainer to me these
are pull all your own money out so you
know at the end would we
will probably
have more to put into something else
it's just so interesting though because
the reason i asked that question because
so often i think people sabotage
themselves out of fear or oh but what
about and they and they think about a
problem that's not a problem today today
the problem is have you got a deal
have you but it's like oh but what
happens if i can't finance it but what
happens if and they're thinking about
tomorrow's problems and i think today's
got enough problems of itself i think if
more people
were saying let me just walk the abc
and then figure out the xyz later the
answer's always on the other side of the
hill let me just walk and then get to it
you know i think i really admire that
about you and i think that's for me i
think that's one of the key reasons to
why you've been so successful
what advice would you give to somebody
that was starting out someone that was
maybe watching the videos but like
yourself a couple years ago had no
property experience but was really
wanting to get into property what advice
knowing what you know now would you give
that person just throw yourself in there
there's been so much that i've learned
along the way that i didn't
even
comprehend it was you know i've just if
you for those throw yourself into it
you're gonna learn like anything you
start you always start anything in life
whatever job you're doing you don't go
into that most of the time knowing the
ins and outs of it yeah so and you throw
yourself into that so why can't you
throw yourself into anything yeah it's
it's like you know i always use the term
of
living around the world it doesn't
matter it's it's a world we all just
live in different parts
so going to
new zealand or somewhere it doesn't
matter i'm just moving it's it's just a
different way it's you know it's
you just do it what do you think the key
differences are between successful
entrepreneurs and people that don't win
or maybe people that just work isn't it
not the same wrong with it but just work
as an employee forever live a normal
life and then people that become super
successful in entrepreneurship what do
you think the difference between the two
are courage
being afraid
being afraid of not succeeding
being afraid of
the
xyz problems
you know the they see the negativity
before they even
see anything else and i think that that
scares a lot of people away
but you can overcome anything if you
want to well i i believe i can you've
also doing bigger deals now as well
which is great it's interesting that you
started off on a little bite and you've
just slowly you've got more
knowledgeable you've built your
connections you're just going bigger and
bigger and bigger i know you've just
used a lease option agreement to buy a
very interesting um project tell me a
little bit about that so um this came
through
actually the science site and i used to
do some um
networking for bni for from a signs and
i actually used the builder from that to
come to a small hmo that um we was we
was doing getting a price
and and then at that when we was at that
meeting he kept mentioning about joint
ventures for for land and other other
projects so i just asked him i said you
keep mentioning about joint ventures
what you got so then he then put us onto
a land agent and this is where this
joint venture deals come from um
and it's
it's real big project two-year option
we've got on a subject to planning
um it's to build nine units plus a
conversion and each unit will be worth a
million each
um
there's a planning gain of 1.1 million
on it
and so it's massive for me this is like
a real learning curve for me you know
it's been great and to to think that
it started just off a little
conversation in
you know me signs
side i think it's brilliant huge that's
incredible i can't believe that i mean
that's like
nine million pound gross development
value and and where are you up to have
you had the heads of terms signed yet
the planning's going through um
and um the the bat survey
um that's been done i think we're having
the second one done soon do you think
people know when they meet you for the
first time or if they don't know you
your story do you think people have got
any idea
how successful you are in property when
they meet you no not at all i still
can't believe it myself
like i said it's gone so fast i'm still
in a whirlwind of still making things
happen so we've got so much more going
on and i don't stop to look at what
we've done what was the moment when you
decided you were going to go all in
because clearly over the last 18 months
or so two years now almost you've been
going fully in
when did you make the decision
from just watching youtube videos and to
just go you know what i'm going in when
when did you make a decision and how did
that come about
in lockdown when i was on the
you you did all the uh nightly calls to
keep everyone motivated and that's when
i just really felt that i had this
passion for it and
i had not done anything i could feel how
and that if i feel something so strongly
i know i'm gonna go for something i
don't i don't feel strongly about
everything you know this it's very i
just know then so when when we actually
met up with everybody i just knew that i
was going to move forward with it
when we've got into rave investment side
and started with that that's when i've
realized there's there's no going back
for me now that's amazing and it's so
funny because when we went to lockdown
you know what a lot of other property
training companies went into hibernation
you know or went bust
and then and i was like right
going to lock down this is the
opportunity now on the phone to
everybody putting on all these virtual
stuff put everything online um and it's
great it's so many people
succeeded over lockdown and and and now
the obviously the property market like
that prop that first property you bought
i bet that's gone up considerably now
what's uh you bought it for 50. now
worth 70. there we go just that little
tiny little 20 grand profit well we're
just gonna refinance him of course you
are
pull out your money and get something
else
how do you feel about that about debt
because
although you're you've got a very large
property portfolio 2 million soon to be
10 million i mean if this one land deal
comes off alone you know that's going to
be huge but with all these millions
obviously there's a lot of debt it's not
all profit you're making 11 000 pounds a
month profit cash flow through rave
which is great
how do you feel about debt does that
scare you at all no
no it really you know my husband as well
he's he's very much like he'll see the
negative in everything every single
thing you'll see the negative but he's
he's just like
now he doesn't even talk about debt he
doesn't talk about
anything negative to because i've i've
just shut it all out i'm like if you
haven't got anything good to say don't
say it at all so now he's just all
positive go and do it he doesn't
it's all about belief you know you've
gotta you've gotta be in debt to make
something yeah you could you start with
two grand yeah right so you might you
might have no debt
but if you've got no debt and no money
and no cash flow and now ask it to know
nothing then you're just going to end up
having to work a job exactly but if you
can make debt your friends yes you might
have a lot of debt but you've also got a
lot of net yeah and it to be a high net
worth you've got to be a high debt worth
as well generally speaking so um that's
super exciting what made you enroll into
the academy the youtube channels it was
i just sat at home i watched one and
then that were i couldn't stop watching
him like my husband says like i feel
like he's moved in with us he's always
on the telly and like my daughter's like
samuel samuel you know oh mommy this
looks like samuel she she recognizes you
and you were just i would just read in
the books i was researching i've still
got a folder at home from when i started
it's like this thick of me writing
everything off your youtube channels and
yeah it's just
i just got addicted to that and then
that's when i was like right we're going
to the crash course and from there that
came the academy and
you know it's from
well from there i've just gone upward i
think as well when you're addicted to
learning and growth most people might
want to watch netflix and but when
you're like no i want to watch property
videos and i want to learn i want to and
you become addicted you you're clearly
addicted to success you're addicted to
winning in property and i think to get
the kind of results that you've got
which are not normal it's super normal i
think that you have to not only work
smart but you have to work really hard
have you need the right people around
you and i think that's you know part of
part of your success is also the fact
that you've had good people dave's
you've partnered with dave who's an
incredible guy he's also been on winners
on a wednesday um and other academy
members and you know i think you're a
real good example of
somebody that knows the power of joint
venture inc
yeah talk to me about joint ventures i
just love working with people
and i love giving people the opportunity
to see what i'm doing what i'm
experiencing and not just that it's
having somebody else there
with us
they can also help along the journey
everybody's got something to give yes
you know no matter what it is so
you know it's it's just a great
experience all around really there's a
saying that says if you want to go fast
go alone but if you want to go far go
together yeah would you agree with that
yes definitely that's that's why we
decided to do it like that there's you
know there's many people out there that
don't want a joint venture and they're
happy
um
but we just felt like our personalities
suited that strategy a lot
and
and it works great you know we meet up
with our jv partners all the time and we
have breakfast and go through things and
even that brings
future
investments as well we've had a couple
of our jv partners now asking us to do
another one
so just from that it can
you know roll on to other things another
thing i talk about a lot is fast pound
and slow pound so build your
developments and your brrs and your
long-term wealth but you need quick cash
flow and i know you're also doing quite
a bit of deal sourcing in fact you sold
a deal this morning right on your way
here yep so dave we're driving um i'm on
my laptop as usual doing all the little
bits that we need to do how much do you
make
uh
three well three nine nine nine
the one sold this morning you just made
four grand
driving here today yeah
incredible what would you say to
somebody that was thinking about coming
along to some of the training maybe the
crash course or the academy but was a
bit like oh on the fence what would your
advice be as if you were talking to a
friend
just go in with an open mind really you
know experience it for yourself
just
let yourself be open to
everything and anything you know if you
if you're a sensible person and you know
what you want it's
it's there for the taking you know so
many people love have said different
things to me you know do this why are
you doing this why do and it's
i'm not i'm not daft i go in i oh and
see what's there
you know i make my own decisions i'm an
adult and
look where i've come from it yeah
because i think people don't blink are
going to university to learn how to
learn a skill to get a job but when
they're going up to become a
professional property investor they're
like oh i don't know if i oh maybe i'll
try and just have a bash and do it for
free and do it and it's like actually if
you're serious about
building something big property
investing although it is simple
you can lose money as well as make money
if you don't know what you're doing and
you can also you know just be doing
vanilla by tillettes when you could be
doing hmos or service accommodation so
you know i personally think that the
best investment to make is not property
i think it's yourself whether that's
investing not just money but also time
into learning and building your network
and
um i would i would agree i think that's
super important
yeah definitely i mean even with that
putting putting money into your
education com everything else just
follows with it if i want to put myself
in that position
and invested in myself then i probably
wouldn't have met dave we probably
wouldn't have investment so yeah you can
sit back and
and you know try and do it yourself but
if you really want to make make
something of it and really focus then
you've got to would you say your
strongest reason for doing this is why
do you work so hard everyone loves the
money you don't we all love them on it
but i i love what i do i'm passionate
about it i love learning about new
things all the time i mean i'm i'm
probably 10 into my journey i've got so
much more to learn and every little bit
more that i do learn i'm like right
what's the next steps i just want to
progress in it and it is just about
me loving it me as a person and you know
i want to i want to grow i want to
inspire my kids
i just want to say from the bottom of my
heart i'm so proud of what you've done
it's been a pleasure working with you
and thank you it's been an absolute
pleasure working with the samuel leeds
team it's been you know i can't thank
you enough where where i've come from
you know being in the academy i would
never achieve that if it weren't for the
people around me so thank you for that
well done well done
guys i am feeling super inspired and my
heart is filled with joy for rebecca and
for everybody else that i see winning in
property this is why i do what i do so
if you enjoyed the interview then please
do drop a nice comment below don't
forget to hit the like button if you
want to see more videos like this i've
got a whole playlist literally for three
years i've been interviewing every
single week one of my success students
so see the whole playlist here subscribe
over here and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you